pounded it gives it up caruso for three  oh caruso with a big hit  quarter three set up by lebron james  and that might do it as the lakers  looking for a put away punch  this is great here and as he comes in on  the mismatch hardin  just starts to fake at him lebron james  finds caruso and he knocks down the  three  alex caruso with 16 and it's knocked  away by caruso  up ahead rondo all the way lebron  james throws it down that was risky  but james made it work there's another  deflection by caruso  alex caruso coming up with a big plays  here late in this game  man this was ill-advised but it works  and it counts caruso  will always bring you great energy and a  great defensive  effort  and westbrook puts up one last three  that's a foul  on rivers on a loose